hey how's it going bros my name is wall
and welcome to two weeks ago I did I did
a video called mean comments where I
read mean comments and made fun of them
and last week I did a video on the whole
fist me daddy tweets and all that
and even though it's really fun
to poke fun of these stupid things I
feel like I also left some of you bros
out in the dirt because I really do get
so many awesome comments and I made
these videos just focusing on the bad
and stupid ones so I wanted to just do
this one it's probably not gonna be a
funny video but I just wanted to make a
video kind of acknowledging the amazing
comments that I really do get from you
bros I collected some of my phone and
just gonna read them it's gonna be a
giant patch in the back for me I really
just wanted to show that I really do
care about about the great comments that
you both leave me Rhonda Martinez says I
didn't think I was able to truly laugh
anymore until I subscribe to you that is
so sweet
Thank You Jessie Ann Thomason I have
been bullied for a long time now but one
day my life changed I went online
my eyes were shocked to see a rare bred
of pants I'm a rare bred thank you
that's that's quite the compliment I
becoming t'en when I was sad and crying
because my dog died I watched your
videos and I didn't feel as sad anymore
thanks for making me smile every day
when I watch your videos brofist I'm
always happy to hear that my videos have
a positive impact on you bros when you
need it I upload videos every single day
for that fact so always be here in a way
jimkar sirs your videos are awesome and
they're one of the best things on their
net album I don't know about that and
even though you don't see yourself as a
celebrity you are just one that actually
speaks to his fans and gives them the
opportunity to speak back stay awesome
thank you I appreciate that I'm 14 and
I'm a cancer patient I'm okay now I was
diagnosed with all acute lymphoblastic
leukemia when I was 11 I had to go
through tons and tons of pain with all
the tests and treatment yeah I heard
leukemia is very painful all I had was
my laptop and not so good internet
connection that sucks
there is at the hospital I like how it
that's that's what I say is the worst
thing Jesus Christ I'm an idiot
I used to cry every night because of the
pain and loneliness but after a couple
months I started watching you I had no
idea how I found you my first video all
I remember is you saying bah bah bah bah
wooden I say that I started watching
your videos day and night and you were
the only youtuber I used to watch after
two years of treatment I won the battle
and I'll never forget how much you
helped thanks mine and breakfast that's
that's so cute I'm so happy my videos
really oh my god Maria Griffin ah so
many comments I doubt you'll see this
but Felix I've been sub since you were
that Shiloh youtuber playing call of
duty yeah that was me and I watched you
grow into the amazing youtuber you are
today thank you you've gotten me through
hard times and I'll always be a bro this
might be a fan appreciation but just
know me and many others appreciate you
the bravest of fist a bro eeeh
sophisticates here yeah it's really cool
people whose watch for a longer time and
I feel like I changed a lot and and
grown a lot throughout the year so and
it's cool to have fans with me
throughout this journey for so for such
a long time Maxie says basically all my
best friends and mine's inside jokes are
references to your videos
salsa when I was deployed to Afghanistan
we had limited access to Internet when I
could get internet I used to gather my
guys around and we would watch happy
wheels prop hunt and troubling terrorize
town for that little bit we forgot all
about being stuck in a war zone and
actually enjoyed life for a while your
videos and humor helped us relax and
unwind thanks Pierce
brofist see that's that's unbelievable
to me these kind of stories it's crazy
Matthew days says I met my girlfriend in
the comment section of one of your
videos okay we hit it off and now we're
together three years bonding over your
videos of course you'll never know how
much I appreciate you and your videos
hey I'm I'm a matchmaker now too
how about that bball King at first I
never liked you what then a friend
showed me one of your photoshop vids I
thought it was awesome so you like me
now Jake Brown I was watching one of
your videos in class and a random guy
asked what I was watching
I said PewDiePie and ever since I said
those words we have been best friends
since bye it's so sweet that's so cute
lazy city I once wanted to be a penguin
but then my parents didn't want it so
watching your videos make me realize
that anyone can be who they want to be
even a duck so beautiful thank you so
glad I helped danique you're mine hi
food hey thank you for making videos
every day and I hope you will enjoy them
for many more years I'm sure I will
and also thanks for replying to comments
again it makes a lot of people happy
even though you never reply to me while
I reply to you technically now I hope
that helps add pity pie you saved my
life I was in a very dark place before
you and no matter what mood I was in no
matter what was going on you always made
me laugh or smile I was bullied a lot so
I left normal school and went
homeschooling now I'm back because you
have make me realize that it doesn't
matter what others think
right what people think you're an
inspiration and one of the most amazing
people in the universe and hopefully one
day we can meet so I can thank you in
person for saving my life all brofist
of you and brodes daily I don't want
this video to be too long but it really
the feedback was just overwhelming just
for me to really understand that the
fact that I really do put so much time
into making these videos every day is
really worth it because so many people
do actually find joy in it and that that
that gives me motivation and that gives
me strength so thank you so much for
just watching my videos even if it's
just something you get a laugh out of or
that it actually helped you I am I'm
happy to be here and happy to make these
videos I was sorry for the background
noise but basically I forgot to tell you
that we have fitted by app with all my
videos on it it's very cool I'm very
proud of this app it's available on
Android or iTunes so if you're a pro I
definitely recommend that you check this
out I'll leave a link to download it in
the description it's free and it's for
you bros and we're also gonna have
exclusive videos coming up first on the
app and I think there's two videos
already coming up today oh look here's
the video Powerpuff Girls that's not up
on my channel but it's up on the app I
basically want to use it as a way to
reward you bros for being extra bro so
yeah check that out and that's all I got
all right price that was all this is so
amazing I'm so blown away by all the
comments I did not expect such amazing
feedback so I thought since everyone
keeps bitching about the comments it's
like a thing every youtuber hates the
comments I thought we could start maybe
a positive movement so I'm gonna tag
some other youtubers I'm gonna tag too
except the guys cinnamon toast ken and
markiplier if they want to do a similar
video I think we should make them do it
and and change change to comments
forever
the good comments are there we just need
to acknowledge them so yeah ask your
fans to share your stories and
yeah it'll be nice it's good times but
anyway if you like this video please go
ahead and leave a like hit subscribe to
come abroad today and I will see you
bras in the next one that's always sorry
about the background noise stay awesome
for us
you